sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
das war gerade ein phänomenales
schauspiel ich weiß gar nicht gehört
angela merkel eigentlich noch der cdu
csu an ich habe das irgendwie nicht
mitbekommen und ich darf sie auch daran
erinnern dass es die cdu gewesen ist
angela merkel die einen linken
ministerpräsidenten in thüringen
zugelassen hat das ist ihr verdienst und
genau deshalb stehen sie so auch in den
umfragen da wir sind derzeit stehen ihre
letzte amtszeit frau merkel war für
deutschland eine periode des
beschleunigten abstiegs ihrem nachfolger
wird ein sanierungsfall hinterlassen ein
land das verunsichert und gespalten ist
ein land dessen repräsentanten sich in
der rolle des moralischen oberlehrers
gefallen aber im ernstfall an konkreten
herausforderungen
dilettantisch scheitern und versagen ein
land dessen wohlstand erodiert und dass
seine ressourcen in beispielloser weise
vergeudet und verschenkt mit dem corona
wieder auf bauvorhaben sie die deutschen
steuerzahler endgültig an eine schulden-
und transferunion ausgeliefert die ezb
geld schwemme ist in der steigenden
inflation der verbraucherpreise
angekommen zusammen mit den
manipulierten 0 und negativzinsen
bedeutet dass die organisierte massen
enteignung der bürger mit hunderten
milliarden wohlstandsverlust görlitz
der 1 er spürt dass auf seinem konto das
keine zinsen mehr abwirft und an seinem
kaufkraftverlust deutschland belegt bei
dem privatvermögen ebenso wie beim
rentenniveau einen verlierer platz in
der eu statt das rentensystem demografie
fest zu reformieren machen sie
ungedeckte zahlungsversprechen wie ist
nach 20 30 weitergehen soll wenn die
geburtenstarken jahrgänge in rente gehen
dafür haben sie keinen plan dafür haben
wir den höchsten schuldenberg unserer
nachkriegsgeschichte nach anderthalb
jahren corona schuldenpolitik ist die
offene staatsschuld um volle zehn
prozentpunkte von 60 auf 70 prozent des
bips gestiegen zusammen mit der
impliziten staatsschuld der
nachhaltigkeitslücke sind das
440 prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes
oder
14,7 billionen euro ihr vizekanzler und
koalitionspartner olaf scholz hat als
finanzminister diesen schuldenberg
maßgeblich zu verantworten und herr
scholz redet viel von respekt hat aber
wenig respekt für die hart arbeitenden
normalen leute die jeden tag aufstehen
zur arbeit fahren viele kinder wo
und dafür laufend bestraft werden ihre
regierung keinen respekt für die
menschen und auch nicht für die
mittelständischen unternehmer und
familienbetriebe die millionen menschen
arbeit geben und wenn es nach rot grün
links geht über eine asoziale vermögens
und erbschaftssteuer enteignet werden
soll demgegenüber
steht der rückfall ins untere mittelmaß
in fast allen bereichen ein bis zwei zu
nennen das bildungswesen und die
digitalisierung in mathematik und
naturwissenschaften sind die leistungen
deutscher schüler unter dem eu
durchschnitt gefallen im internationalen
vergleichstest deutschland seit 2007 vom
zwölften auf den 25 platz gefallen im
digitalen ranking steht deutschland
inzwischen an drittletzter stelle unter
den g20-staaten abgehängt auch von
frankreich und italien an dass wir
dutzende milliarden an sogenannte korona
wiederaufbauhilfe leisten
ein weiteres ungelöstes problem dieser
regierung ist die migrations krise
nach wie vor
wandert jedes jahr eine großstadt neu in
unser land reisen und direkt in die
sozialsysteme
dass sie das super finden das wissen wir
es reicht offenbar nicht was sie mit
ihrem vorsätzlichen rechtsbuch von 2015
über dieses land und seine bürger
gebracht haben jetzt missbraucht diese
regierung die ortskräfte die der
bundeswehr in afghanistan gedient haben
um die nächste einwanderungswelle nach
deutschland loszutreten von rund 4.000
bis in unterlagen der afghanen waren
ganze 168 ortskräfte aber mehr als 250
personen ganz ohne papiere darunter
bereits abgeschobene straftäter polizei
bekannte kriminelle vergewaltiger
kinderschänder
islamisten die auf staatskosten geholt
wurden und in folge des neuerlichen
abschiebestopps auf unabsehbare zeit
bleiben werden während andere staaten
sich auf die sicherheit und die
rohstoffe in der region fokussieren
interessiert sich die deutsche politik
vor allem für die evakuierung von
ausreisewilligen afghanischen das
versagen in der asyl- und
migrationspolitik wird als größte
fehlleistung der endzeit von
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen
die finanzielle zukunft belastung für
unser land summiert sich auf über eine
billion euro noch schwerer wiegt der
schaden den der kontrollverlust für den
inneren frieden die sicherheit der
bürger das vertrauen in die institution
und den inneren zusammenhalt des landes
bedeutet auch ihre fehlgeleitete
klimaschutz und energiewende politik wir
teuer zu stehen kommen aber milliarden
werden jahr für jahr verbrannt um die
taschen der windkraft und ökostrom lobby
zu füllen während deutschland sich im
planwirtschaftlichen gestrüpp von e auto
subventionierung und co2 besteuerung
verhindert die rationale idee
kohle und atomkraftwerke
gleichzeitig abzuschalten braucht einem
industrieland wie deutschland den
lebensnerv die sichere und bezahlbare
energieversorgung
mit dem gleichen foto wollen sie die
elektromobilität herbei subventionieren
ohne sich um die fragwürdige
umweltbilanz und die begrenzte
verfügbarkeit der rohstoffe für die
dafür erforderliche batterieproduktion
zu kümmern wo er übrigens der
zusätzliche strom für all die
elektroautos kommen soll die sie auf die
straße bringen wollen darüber haben sie
sich offensichtlich keine gedanken
gemacht
oder glauben sie ernsthaft sie könnten
die deutsche industrie auf wind- und
sonnenstrom und grünen wasserstoff
umstellen wissen sie was sie dafür
brauchen
dafür müssten sie die zahl der windräder
auf
330.000 verzehnfachen und ein viertel
der landesfläche mit rotor türmen zu
betonieren und wenn dann der wind nicht
weht dann drehen sich diese trotzdem
nicht so nachhaltige politik aus wir
sagen ganz klar
mit solchen unausgegorenen ideen machen
sie unser land zum gespött der welt und
die deutschen zu verlierern im globalen
wettbewerb
niemand in europa oder anderswo auf der
welt denkt ernsthaft daran die deutsche
energiewende zu kopieren wir sind der
einzige hit i start und das muss man
hier ganz klar so sagen der einzige
staat der diesel durchgeknallten ideen
ernsthaft umsetzen möchte koste was es
wolle whatever it takes wie draghi zu
sagen pflegt in den letzten zwei
jahrzehnten hat sich der strompreis in
deutschland verdoppelt und die
eeg-umlage seit
2014 fast als folge der weltfremden
klimaziele dieser koalition droht im
nächsten jahr über die anhebung der
sogenannten co2 bepreisung der anstieg
der spritkosten und bis zu 70 cent pro
liter
das bedeutet preise weit jenseits der
zwei euro marke auch wenn der
verkehrsminister anderes verspricht das
schützt weder das klima noch rettet es
dem planeten aber es macht pendler und
familien die auf das auto angewiesen
sind es ruiniert mittelständler und
treibt die produktive industrie und
hunderttausende von arbeit plätzen aus
diesem land
und in all diesen finanziellen lasten
beunruhigt eine zahl in der bilanz der
regierung besonders von allen eu bürgern
fühlen die deutschen sich am wenigsten
frei
nur elf prozent sehen sich noch als frei
in ihrem alltagsleben die
orientierungslose und maßlose krone
politik dieser bundesregierung hat daran
erheblichen anteil reihum suchen immer
mehr unsere europäischen nachbarn den
weg zurück in die normalität sie aber
mauern dieses land mitsamt seinen
menschen in einem permanenten
ausnahmezustand ein und stach mit
vernunft und augenmaß
obsolet gewordene maßnahmen
zurückzufahren schikanieren sie schüler
und jugendliche auch im neuen schuljahr
mit masken und des regimes deren nutzen
bis heute nicht bewiesen ist und sie
brechen aber war als das versprechen
dass sie den bürgern gegeben haben und
zwar wenn jeder der dazu bereit ist ein
kaufangebot gemacht wurde müssen die
maßnahmen ende es liegt jetzt in der
verantwortung jedes einzelnen
und seiner persönlichen risiko abwägung
ob er sich für eine impfung oder andere
vorkehrungen zu seinem eigenen schutz
entscheidet oder nicht es ist eine
individuelle entscheidung und sie
spalten das land und die gesellschaft
wenn sie menschen aufgrund dieser
persönlichen entscheidung
gegeneinander ausspielen und ungeimpfte
als bürger zweiter klasse vom
gesellschaftlichen leben ausschließen
alle alarmglocken bisschen schrill denn
aus politiker muss ungeimpfte als sozial
schädlinge diffamiert werden und selbst
ein vizekanzler geimpfte als
versuchskaninchen bezeichnet und sie
haben faktisch ein impfzwang aus und es
so zu nennen um sich aus der
verantwortung für die folgen ihrer
falschen entscheidungen zu stehlen seit
anderthalb jahren betreiben sie unter
dem namen der pandemie bekämpfung eine
politik der gebrochenen versprechen und
der überzogenen grundrechts
einschränkung von reiseeinschränkungen
und lockte am berufsverboten über
ausgangssperren und notstandsmaßnahmen
diffamierung und
demonstrationsverbote gegen kritiker bis
zum impfzwang und drastischen eingriffen
in den eltern und kinderrechte und sie
sagen und sie hören auf die wissenschaft
wenn sie jetzt schon wieder spekulieren
welche neuen grundrechts entzüge sie
nach der wahl wieder umsetzen könnten
und meinen damit stets nur jene
wissenschaftler die ihnen nach dem mund
reden nehmen sie also endlich andere
standpunkte zur kenntnis zum beispiel
die stimme der 100 ärzten juristen und
unternehmer die in einem offenen brief
klaren und verbindlichen aussagen zum
ende der pandemie politik fordern hören
sie auf mit angstparolen und panikmache
die bürger von den vielen drängenden
themen abzulenken
stellen sie endlich die grundrechte
vollumfänglich und für alle wieder her
damit dieses land so normalität
zurückkehren und sich nach einer
schonungslosen und ehrlichen
bestandsaufnahme der gesamtheit seiner
probleme und herausforderung zuwenden
kann ich bin dann kann es
[Applaus]